for the next step in Troy's
rehabilitation Cesar asks the Adler's to
participate in a dog obedience class at
a Los Angeles Park Cesar's longtime
friend and colleague OJ nitin teaches
the class go whit now he this is bad we
often say look for a profession or they
help you to go in the right direction
see here if your dog is aggressive they
don't tell you to go away they tell you
how to get rid of the aggression or how
to redirect the aggression that's what
we need as a society you know somebody
they show us how to do it
Oh Jay a dog trainer in behavior expert
for 20 years currently works with more
than 300 people who are enrolled in his
classes I believe in focus focus it's a
way for the dog to watch me she's
watching me he trusts me so I show him
what I want so now he said what what do
you want I have complete attention then
if there are distraction around whether
it be noise another dog a person running
down the street
he's still looking from me for a command
cannibal places like this gives you
access to see ok what is my role model
German Shepherd woman yes all right so
that's the picture that's good to have
you know at home and to keep it in mind
I want to walk him and doggie together
there you go this is a guy that I was
telling you about
hello hi Troy first thing I want to do
is making a positive introduction for me
okay hey boy good and that was positive
ah yeah he has to trust us Odie decides
to determine the level of Troy's dog
aggression tom
Lamine i need you to bring pj what i do
what a dog aggressive dog is been
introduced into dogs that are under
control the dog is never gonna trust you
if all the other dogs out of control
then we have no red tug if I have a big
tug take him out take him out I'm taking
him out because he's giving me a little
bit more contact other dogs they
challenge each others with their eyes
and I want this dog to definitely trust
me so I'm gonna remove that situation
that's a good thing to know about
trainers is they know when to remove an
energy that is not going to help you and
when to bring an energy that is gonna
help you everybody here is here to help
even by moving away they can help you
sure he wants to play but he just don't
know how to play Tom the Lu he was
redirecting him with food it worked
so now he's trying to find out if a toy
can also work so those become your two
tools that you can use for obedience
purpose but the most part too is your
energy so now I'm getting a doll focus
[Music]
is more prey this is definitely have
brought more predator side of him bojay
uses a device called a flirt pole with
an attached chamois to try and determine
the intensity of Troyes prey drive you
see the focus I've created
[Music]
so now I got somebody like now I can
challenge that energy what is good this
dog has prey Drive mm-hmm so I can get
him focus and not worry about the dog
[Music]
it's getting places so the dogs dogs are
like that we can only do one thing at a
time say he found what you know what
tickles him I guess you got to give us
that toy okay